all right so before we get this video
started I'd like to tell you guys that I
am currently at college and so videos
may be a little different um as far as
the merching series goes and in future
videos of this merching series since
this is the beginning of the video it is
probably going to be most likely post
commentary because just with people in
and out of the room and all that just so
much going on there's not a lot of time
for me to sit down make everyone be
quiet and then go ahead with commentary
for a 10 to 15 second clip it's more
likely just going to be me eventually
recording over it with regular
commentary and a couple Clips maybe in
which I have just regular commentary
nonetheless um this this Series has been
a little delayed these flips are from a
few weeks back and the main reason that
I haven't been flipping as of late is
due to the fact that my main account got
hacked and then after that I just kind
of wasn't feeling the whole flipping
thing but now that I'm back at school
and now that I have a lot of just time
where I'm on my computer cuz I'm doing
homework and [__] like that um I will be
merching a lot more so you guys can
expect those videos to come back out
very soon so we're going to get into the
video and then I will have a little talk
with you guys at the end all right I
don't think my buckingam sold cuz
nothing up here at the bottom right hand
corner of my screen so it is what it is
but uh yeah that's depressing oh [__] me
right God damn it I just got back from
work and I still can't sell this [__]
and two of them have been bought oh my
God how y'all doing
um yeah something a little different I
decided you know [__] the buck Helms and
uh bought these for
3.4 it was like what 3.45 I believe so I
was able to make pretty much 2 point or
250k off each one of these so quick 750k
made I didn't have to buy and sell one
to find the margins so uh yeah worked
out pretty well for me I accidentally
took the offer out but I ended up
flipping another one of these so we've
made a mill off of these I think that is
about all we're going to make since no
more I've bought but uh that's good
while we got it if this is able to sell
on right now I'll be at pretty much what
77 or 97 mil well the meantime has come
what is that even well here we are so I
bought 10 Elder tops I'm going to sell
them all on for
969k and apparently didn't [__] click
it but yeah so we're about to make
probably like 55k I think off of all of
these and so in total that means I got
550k obviously
here we go boys so basically what you're
going to need to do is just disregard
the uh the mass amount of things in here
this is all for my other account and uh
I was just using this account to buy out
some of the stuff so basically Elder
chaos tops have bought and as you can
see we were able to buy those for 914
which means we made like 27k per one
well actually made a little bit more but
uh it wasn't it wasn't anything too bad
I always enjoyed merching those just cuz
I always seem to have a decent margin
never anything outstanding but you know
something for a little bit of guaranteed
money what's going on boys and girls I
hate myself so this bucket Helm not
looking good last one that's been sold
sold for 63 mil which would mean I lose
9 M selling off this bucket home which I
do not want to do but right now I'm
going to think of actually a merch that
is a little different and uh basically
page sets of zamrock pages are
definitely easier to buy than uh you
know each page individually and I'm sure
there's a lot less of them on Market so
you can build your own margin on these
things so let's do it um I believe I
added all this up pretty well so this is
a fun little merch that I am going to be
doing right now so basically um give me
one second I'm going to re add all this
up cuz it doesn't seem to be coming out
to the right number at all all right so
basically I bought five zamrock page
sets for 12.9 mil and I'm going to put
them all together and sell them on for
2.64 five each and see how much profit
that we can make off of these if they do
all sell don't think I necessarily
utilize the uh these selling off in page
sets merged as well as I could have I
could have found the margins and stuff
like that however I decided to go
against that and not do that which will
result in barely a 200k profit um these
page ones however had bought while I was
at work and they all bought for 726 and
I believe I can make about 40K on all of
them so uh make a little bit of money
there at this point we're going to dump
the bucket hel for 2o loss um it
actually went back up which is good it
dropped to 61 it's back up to around 60
869 so I'm hoping we can sell it off
there I'll take a 2 mil loss I don't
think it's going to go back up above 70
anytime soon however I could be wrong so
there we go finish off selling all of
the page sets and uh yeah going to have
to wait for these things to sell on
however if you look at our bank we have
24 mil once that all sells off so we add
on this basically 70 mil we're 94 point
or like 93.5 around there so uh yeah the
buck Helm hurt us a little bit but I'm
just going to be happy to get my
cashback so I can actually do some
merchesi not being able to do anything
because of this [__] thing oh my God
finally okay so all these name Rock
Pages have sold I'm trying to buy a
sadan ornament kit but that's not going
well at all I'm going to see what the
bucket Helm G's selling for I don't want
to inst toell it just cuz that'd be dumb
of me to do but I do what it say that a
bucket Helm is sold for
77.2 mil what all right I'm going to
list this back up for uh 76 mil and we
can see if this sells at all I don't
know why it didn't sell
because it says that that was insta sold
for 76 mil or
77.2 I was not able to sell this I don't
know why I wasn't able to I'm pretty
pissed right now to be honest though
what what is going on I didn't expect
this at all I was literally just about
to record an intro for my uh for the
video I'm uploading right now what am I
going to be able to sell this for um all
right well apparently it's dipped a
little bit but you know what I'm not
scared I'll list this thing up for 1505
okay and uh yeah that'll sell for an
800k profit
guaranteed can't wait to go see all my
items that I've uh bought so morning and
uh the default merch is done again so
basically these had like 22k margins or
something and I bought and sold pretty
much like 10 of them so I made somewhere
around 250k cuz I had a little bit over
20k margins initially so uh yeah well we
sold on something so there we go sold on
the sadan god sword ornament kit for a
400k profit I do believe and treasonous
Rings I bought the margin and found it
and then I are you [__] kidding me
uhoh [__] alert I bought I I bought
the margin found it and uh yeah so we
can sell this on for
14.9 and get our money back I do believe
yo shout out to PJ XR and book of meow
for joining the clan chat but this is
about to be the happiest you have ever
seen a man that had just lost 2.5 mil on
a merch look at this [__] finally it's
finally sold I don't care I don't care
that I lost money on it this was a
pretty good price to sell it at and I'm
just happy that that's done so as you
can see we have 69 mil right here and
then we have another 30 right here and
now you would be like oh man we're about
to hit 100 Mil that's wrong because I
have about 5 mil on this account that
was from my main that I forgot to
transfer back over so going to have to
do that and uh yeah nonetheless we can
finally do some regular merges man I've
been stuck on these things for like 3 to
4 days now that bucka Helm has took up
70% of my cash so I am so happy all
right so it is the morning and this is
the only thing that we have of note that
we can do so uh we bought an armadel
ornament kit or an armadel God Sword
ornament kit and I believe I can sell
this on for around 11.65 mil somewhere
around there so we should be able to
make 500k off of it hopefully all right
so here we are and just got back from
golfing as you can see barely anything
is bought I had to lower the sell price
in this armadil God Sword ornament kit
hopefully we'll make 100K on that the
torture bought for 10.5 I uh currently
am invested in these on my main account
but we're going to try and flip this for
say
10.85 maybe 86 we'll try that hey so we
were able to sell on the torture
ornament kit set which is actually
pretty good we also sold a gilded set
which we had bought for the same price
but as you can see at least at the time
the Gilded set had over a 300K margin or
almost exactly a 300K margin however no
more bought so I'm not entirely sure if
it just was at the time or something
like that well failed merch is failed so
basically as you can see none of those
gilded armor sets have bought after I
went to work which means obviously I
guess my offer just wasn't going through
for some reason and the grand exchange a
little bit annoying although it is what
it is I guess so we're just going to
cancel that out all these gilded plate
legs have bought so I'm pretty much just
going to buy one and see what I can sell
them on for and uh hopefully we can just
go with that I did not mean to Auto
collect all of that because I was going
to talk over it however we're going to
do what we can so it looks like we're
going to H we're still actually going to
make some decent money on these they
just lower a little bit so that's not
too bad at all just kind of weird that
none of them were able to sell in the 6
hours I was at work treasonous ring has
one up so I'm just literally probably
just going to get the margin back to be
totally honest with you and torture
ornament kit has bought we'll have to
check and see what the price of that is
but we will list that up now that was
quick as [__] let's let's I just got
done eating let's run with these torture
ornament kits that seems like the uh the
play that we're going to have for the
night I can obviously list them up for
higher and hopefully I can buy them for
like 105 2 so before I hop off I'm going
to update you guys with what's going on
all the crystal Keys have bought my
trees and ring sold on to pretty much
get the margin that we found back so we
really didn't make anything off of those
and one of the Gilded plate leg sets has
or just gilded plate legs have bought so
we have another 25 mil to go ahead and
throw at some stuff so I'm going to do
that before I go to sleep probably throw
it at a siden ornament kit and other
than that I really have no clue what I
want to do I have to kind of stray away
from these clue scroll items since I've
been doing them recently in my merch
videos
um however this sidan thing seems like
it could be a uh a good idea so we're
going to rock this for the night
hopefully one of them will buy and uh
yeah we'll be back in the morning with
probably nothing bought cuz I'm terrible
at this of late so pretty interesting
right before I actually was about to get
off I was just looking up some videos on
YouTube um as you can see I found that
there was 110k margins on these Fury
ornament kits so I decided I was going
to put in an offer for 50k less than the
ornament kit said it was buying for and
hopefully I'd be able to buy some
overnight however as you can see I was
able to get it right away which means I
then have the highest Buy offer in which
means therefore and you all should do
this as well you should lower your Buy
offer because if you get something like
this as soon as you put an offer in that
means you have the highest offer and you
don't want to have the highest offer
even though you do you don't want to
have the highest offer and not know that
there's someone right behind you like if
you know there's someone one GP under
you that's perfect but if you don't know
you want to just instinctively lower it
and oh my God that Fury ornament kit
flipped literally within a couple
minutes so we're going to we're going to
keep that going I think so I'm going to
put another one for 3475 and uh yeah
these might be bought by the morning
here we are and it is the morning
luckily enough we had all of our Crystal
Key sell off and all of our gilded plate
legs so we made you know [__] 300K
maybe on the guilded plate legs no other
or no other ornament kits bought which
is a little depressing last torture kit
has bought we're going to L set up while
we go or while I go to work you guys
will not be joining me on this adventure
and uh yeah I'm probably going to take
out the offers for the rest of this
stuff and buy something along the lines
of like U seeds or tooth Hales while I'm
at work so I can have something going on
while I am there well let's just say my
time at work obviously didn't get well
cuz I wasn't able to buy any of these
two halfs which is around the price that
they said that it was on RS budy and was
only able to buy 33 new seeds so I'm
pretty upset about that and I'm happy I
didn't sell all those on cuz I would
have been pretty pissed off so 2511
we're going to up our offer a th000
coins and yeah go from there hopefully I
don't get [__] undercut this time bro
I hate that I hate it I hate it I hate
it well didn't expect this but all 200
of my 4our buy limit for U seeds have
bought up and I think that's because no
yeah all right I have the right price on
for them so I'm going to see what the U
sapping price is right now so we can
have an idea so what we can sell these
for overnight ooh 100K if this doesn't
oh dang it all right well 98.9 that's
still that's still good we'd be making
8K at least on each one that we bought
so this could be like a 2 mil merch in
total all right here we go going to
trade back over the U saplings in a
second and here we go 233 of them they
should sell on for about 99k which would
mean we'd be making about 7K per one I
do believe so uh we're going to go ahead
and do that now I think there we go I
think that's about as much as I could
ask for whenever I got on in the morning
so all of my torture ornament kits have
sold I I believe I made 2 to 300K on
each one of these so probably about a
mill in total hopefully um these Unholy
page sets bought as you can see I found
the margins last night and I was like I
could probably get this for about 30k
less than the current margin which I was
able to do so I'm going to try to list
these up for
2575 which would mean I probably will
make 100K on all of these assuming that
they are able to sell and then we have
all the you saplings which have sold on
so that's a nice profit we honestly made
like 7 to 8K on each one of these us
saplings so in total we probably made
about 1.5 mil on that alone and then we
have one gilded set that is bought I
found the margins last night I do
believe no I didn't find the margins at
all I think I just took a stab in the
dark at that one but uh yeah we were
able to grab one so that's pretty cool
um last night I wasn't even buying for
this price so I'm just going to list it
up for 3 or 3650 and hopefully that'll
sell basically I'm going to go and watch
a golf match right now it was just uh my
high school's golf match me and my
friend used to play so we're just going
to go up there and watch with the coach
and it's probably just going to be chill
as [__] but uh we're going to go through
the bank worth currently real quick so
assuming this sell is
9.6 add on this you got 16
3 uh 21 and then we'll just take that
out it's a 21 + 7 so 28 so you had 20
[__] me all right so 21 added on to this
so we are currently at probably around
97. like yeah 97 mil is what we're at so
all right so with that being said
that'll be it for the end of this video
basically um I got hacked right after
this whole thing got made they tried
hacking my merch account however they
ended up getting my main account and got
hacked for 50 mil I obviously made
videos about that a couple weeks ago if
you guys want to check those out
nonetheless with that being said this is
where the video is going to end I now am
going to transfer back over 95 mil onto
the merch account and all of the merch
videos you guys see from here on out
should be pretty up to date I know this
one lagged behind a few weeks in time
but I just had a ton of stuff
pre-recorded and uh yeah that's it for
me nonetheless if you guys enjoyed the
video feel free to hit the like if you
guys have anything improve that I can
improve upon comment that down below if
you guys want to see more hit the sub
button and with that being said hope you
guys have a wonderful day and peace also
join 07 helpers Clan cat nonetheless get
to the outro
[Music]
[Applause]
boys my
my my true